it's gonna be great it's gonna be great
it's gonna be
[Music]
we know that the sea calls to you Moana
after all your name means ocean in
Hawaiian and it's the perfect name for
you it's strong and beautiful and flows
easily off the tongue but not everyone
knows you as Moana several countries in
Europe had to change your name and the
reason why will make you blush
we're sorry it's not your fault some of
the most iconic Disney characters of all
time don't have the same names in other
countries sometimes there's a
translation error and sometimes it's
something more scandalous check out
these ten Disney character names that
were changed in other countries Scrooge
McDuck
we are totally loving the reboot of duck
tales Scrooge McDuck is the rich grumpy
uncle of Huey Dewey and Louie he's named
after the rich grumpy character Avenues
er Scrooge from a Christmas carol in
English it's normal to call a mean and
stingy person Scrooge but not in Spanish
in Mexico this famous character is Rico
Mikado which means rich McDuck that name
makes a lot of sense but so does Scrooge
which name do you think is better
Elsa the Queen from frozen is one of the
most popular Disney characters of all
time she has taught little girls
everywhere how to let it go and feed
themselves
she is really popular in China too but
her name in the Mandarin Chinese dubs is
in Tulsa it's similar to her real name
but it sounds more like Aishah if you're
ever in China and someone mentions that
they love Aisha you'll know that they're
talking about the ice queen goofy Mickey
Mouse's best friend is almost as easy to
recognize as the mouse himself goofy is
a talking dog who is well a little goofy
I just wanted to tell you
but kids in France know him as something
else entirely he is called dingo in
French a dingo is a type of canine but
in France it can also mean nuts or nut
case is goofy really crazy or is he just
silly we wonder how he would feel about
his French name knowing goofy he'd
probably just laugh it off Tinkerbell
the sassy fairy from Peter Pan started
as a background character but in the
1990s and early 2000s Tinkerbell took on
a life of her own
she had several shows and movies all
about her
her name was Tinkerbell because she
tinkered around with things made of
metal but in Mexico that part of her
name is left out she is called camp
Anita which means little Bell it fits
it's a really pretty name for our
favorite pixie your are there any
characters more iconic than the stuffed
animals from the Hundred Acre Wood there
have been so many shows in movies based
on Winnie the Pooh Christopher Robin
just came out in 2018 everyone loves the
sad donkey er but that is not his name
in most other countries in some places
his name sounds similar to his English
name but in Poland
his name is clafouti it doesn't really
mean anything except your how funny is
that
Cogsworth Beauty and the Beast is one of
Disney's most popular movies ever and to
the 2017 remake bright the castle
survives in a whole new way we love
Cogsworth the beasts loyal clock butler
he's a little grumpy but he's a good guy
he's named after the cogs that make Fox
work but in Dutch whose name is Kony
that is the last name of a famous Dutch
clock maker but Kony's lived in 1800 and
Beauty and the Beast takes place in the
1700s that makes Cogsworth older than
the clock maker we hope no history buffs
picks up on this Winnie the Pooh Ursa no
puffs might sound like a new member of
the Powerpuff Girls but it's not you
might be shocked to discover that this
is actually everyone's favorite loveable
huggable bear what a wonderful idea but
Winnie the Pooh didn't translate well to
Portuguese it doesn't really mean
in English either instead his Portuguese
name literally translates to teddy bear
so that's definitely what he is it's a
totally adorable name flounder ever
since the live-action Little Mermaid was
announced we've been catching up with
Ariel and all her fishy friends flounder
is her shy but loyal BFF in English a
founders a type of fish but his name is
even cuter in Finnish and Finland they
call him Park C which means splash
splash would be such an adorable name in
English too we wonder if flounder will
be in the new movie we sure hope so
Mickey Mouse for decades Mickey Mouse
has been the face of Disney in most
countries the world's most famous Mouse
has the same name but not in Italy
his name is topolino in Italian and that
means little mouse and in case you were
wondering Minnie Mouse has the female
version of the name she goes by toe
Polina we can't imagine Mickey by any
other name there's a whole Disney song
that relies on spelling his name out
Moana the most recent Disney princess
made a lot of ways she is the first
Polynesian princess and Moana is one of
the only two Disney Princess movies to
not feature a love story she is super
popular all over the world but she is a
totally different name in Italy Moana
means ocean and the movie is still
called back but her name in Italian is
Diana why well because Moana is the name
of a famous Italian woman but she is
famous for making a certain type of
adult movies this wasn't the image
Disney wanted so they changed her name
have you ever watched a Disney movie in
a different language if so tell us what
was different in the comment section
below
Disney characters with totally different
names in other countries thank you all
Elmo so much
and thanks for watching give this video
a big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe we'll catch you next time on
the things
[Music]